[Applaudissements]
enfin les enfants au soir le pape en vue
du oui c'est vrai
bonsoir les papas et paul fait les papas
bon l'échelle pas trop cheveux
[Musique]
popopopop
bonsoir les enfants
qui sait aujourd'hui c'est la fête des
papas je suis alors tu chantes avec nous
oui
quel toit si la fin des débats que
va-t-on faire pour la fête des pères
tu verras on ira comme deron pour
l'affecter pavane
du droit ohada mais voilà ce qu ils font
faire pour la fête des pères
que je vais jusqu'à toi quand tu es sur
mu mais toi
moi sur un cahier couvert de papier j'ai
fait un dessin avait été du goût là
je me suis appliqué pour la terminer
j'aimerais bien grand soin jamie
4-6 6-7 à bonn exercice qu'il ne faut le
faire pour la fête des mères
je crois que ça
[Musique]
l'a fort que la fois tout dépend de
mon petit papa d'an avait déjà dans ta
grande avoir entendu dire waouh
maintenant tu vas voir tu auras
[Musique]
il faudrait que l'on puisse
dire
voilà papa qui ont de la chance
ils étaient bien surpris quand on lui a
chanté la chanson nous l'aimons beaucoup
notre copain c'est notre petit
vous êtes de gentils enfants
bonne nuit
là j'éteins la lumière
en nuit de noce tête bourrée
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants et bonne fête les
papas bonne fête les enfants et bonne
nuit les new seul contre boni les
enfants et bonne fête les papas ou
allons en route nounours
bonne nuit fait pour eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore
oh
[Musique]